[Music]
a whip like strong powerful crushing
blades a pointed piercing tube there are
nearly a million known insect species in
the world but most have one of just five
common types of mouth parts and that's
extremely useful to scientists because
when they encounter an unfamiliar insect
in the wild they can learn a lot about
it just by examining how it eats
scientific classification or taxonomy is
used to organize all living things into
seven levels kingdom phylum class order
family genus and species the features of
an insects mouth parts can help identify
which order it belongs to while also
providing clues about how it evolved and
what it feeds on the chewing mouth part
is the most common it's also the most
primitive all other mouth parts are
thought to have started out looking like
this one before evolving into something
different it features a pair of jaws
called mandibles with toothed inner
edges that cut up and crush solid foods
like leaves or other insects you can
find this mouth part on ants from the
Hymenoptera order grasshoppers and
crickets of the Orthoptera order
dragonflies of the odana to order and
beetles of the Coleoptera order the
piercing sucking mouth part consists of
a long tube-like structure called a beak
this beak can pierce plant or animal
tissue to suck up liquids like sap or
blood it can also secrete saliva with
digestive enzymes at liquefy food for
easier sucking insects in the Hemet dura
order have piercing sucking mouthparts
and include bedbugs cicadas skate foods
and leaf hoppers the siphoning mouthpart
a friendlier version of the piercing and
sucking beak also consists of a long
tube-like structure called a proboscis
that works like a straw to suck up
nectar from flowers insects of the
Lepidoptera order butterflies and moths
keep their proboscis rolled up tightly
beneath their heads when they're not
feeding and unfurl them when they come
across some sweet nectar what
the sponging math part there's yet
another tube this time ending in two
spongy lobes that contain many finer
tubes called pseudo trachea the pseudo
trachea secrete enzymes filled saliva
and soak up fluids and dissolved foods
by capillary action house flies fruit
flies and the other non biting members
of the Diptera order are the only
insects that use this technique but
there's a catch fighting flies with in
Diptera like mosquitoes horse flies and
deer flies have a piercing sucking mouth
part instead of the sponging mouth part
and finally the chewing lapping mouth
part is a combination of mandibles and a
proboscis with a tongue like structure
at its tip for lapping up nectar on this
type of mouth part the mandibles
themselves are not actually used for
eating for bees and wasps members of the
Hymenoptera order they serve instead as
tools for pollen collecting and wax
molding of course in nature there are
always exceptions to the rules the
juvenile stages of some insects for
example have completely different kinds
of mouths than their adult versions like
caterpillars which use chewing
mouthparts to devour leaves before
metamorphosis into butterflies and moths
with siphoning mouth parts still mouths
part identification can for the most
part help scientists and you categorize
insects so why not break out a
magnifying lens and learn a little more
about who's nibbling your vegetable
garden biting your arm or just flying by
your ear
did you know that insects outnumber
humans by more than a billion to one
find out the secret to their success in
this video
[Music]